would you say like um because a lot of
artists like you said they'll they'll
get a deal and they won't worry so much
about the terms but they'll
maybe they'll get that front end advance
yeah of course and they're like yes it's
beautiful the front end advance is
beautiful you know what i'm saying but
it ain't right
for people who don't know like what is
because i always try to tell artists
like look like an advance is cool but
it's not it it's really all that matters
are your terms because you got to pay
that money back you got to give it back
you got to give it back and it's most of
the time it's at a really bad rate
and you know i think a lot of young
artists they make that mistake where
they run to whoever's
you always hear about bidding wars and
[ __ ] you'll be like well who's got the
biggest advance yeah sometimes it ain't
it's mo it's not about that for the rain
because you you can get you can get a
large ass advance and don't you know
what i'm saying don't succeed on the
other side i mean you talk about yg you
know
i was talking to yg i mean this is on
video so it's not like this he's like i
haven't seen any money off my music for
real yeah he probably got a crazy ass
event yeah no because he signed with def
jam and he just re-upped but before that
like he was like bro like yeah when he
was unhappy with def jam it was because
he probably
yeah i know yo you got you know
something you gotta have there's
somebody with platinum records yeah i
would never thought that you know saying
you gotta have them good lawyers on your
you know saying you gotta be in
communication with your lord you can
have a lawyer but if you ain't talking
to him yeah young blue just told us that
right yeah young blue was like i got
three in the uh three was it with
columbia he had three gold records he
said i ain't catching a check a lot of
folks go through that same [ __ ] yeah but
you got to go through you know say it's
real at the end of the day is how long
you gonna you're gonna stand for that
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying it's also like
would you rather have the quick nut or
like the consistent residual bag every
month exactly i take the residual bag
yep you get what i'm saying but i went
to the same phase you know what i'm
saying during that time during that 2016
17 period now you see a check i ain't
seen a music check in two years
you know what i'm trying to get off that
advance right i had to live off just you
know i'm saying the show that i had you
know what i'm saying and the [ __ ] i had
saved up and had to figure this [ __ ] out
and to the point where you know i'm
saying i did what i did and i cracked
you know i'm saying the conversation
with the with the with the uppers you
know and [ __ ] got straightened